[Music]
christopher's in oklahoma city hi
christopher how are you
hi i'm
pretty good i guess good how can we help
oh i have problems
um well
so we had uh some fraudulent
transactions on our account and
my wife was talking about getting a uh
a credit card
because she makes uh
online transactions and to
i guess i i guess they uh they're easy
part is easier to handle
in credit cards
um and
i mean
i've watched you guys er yeah i've
watched your youtube stuff all the time
uh for years
so i know i wanted to know what you
would recommend
to prevent fraud
preferably something free
yeah
well fraud is uh has the if you
get a fraudulent transaction on a credit
card
you don't owe the money if you get a
fraudulent transaction on a debit card
you don't owe the money
and so the net result of both is no loss
to you it's both free
visa has the in mastercard have the
exact same protections for fraud on
debit as they do on credit now on your
debit it can come out of your account
and it made it be a little bit before
you get it put back into the account but
the bank is on the hook for that
transaction not you
so you do not have a greater risk
of losing money with a debit card than
you do with a credit card so that's just
bogus now here's the other thing if
she's bouncing around where she's
showing doing online crap where she's
showing up with fraud all the time
she needs to she needs to fix her dead
gum ways i mean what are you doing what
kind of sites are you hanging out on
that's crazy i'm not going to continue
to a behavior pattern that's inviting
fraud into anything
yeah i
don't think she's like
going crazy online i mean like this is
the first time we've noticed this well i
mean what how many different fraudulent
transactions were there
uh there were two
but they'd shut down them yesterday oh
my god that's just ridiculous you're
going to completely change your whole
way of handling money over two
fraudulent transactions i had a
fraudulent transaction on my debit card
last week they shut it down removed it
instantly
shut the card down for 48 hours reopen
we're done
i'm not going to completely change my
whole life over two transactions you
live in a world where you're gonna have
a fraudulent transaction occasionally i
thought you were talking like you had
100 or something yeah she needs to just
make sure she's got the right security
measures in place when she's shopping
online don't store your card info make
sure you've got secure passwords don't
use the same passwords across sites this
is basic if she really wants security
this is how she's going to get it not
from a credit card and so that's going
to be a conversation you have to have
with her it sounds more like a marriage
conversation than it is a financial
question but
she has to understand that it has the
same protections you'll be okay there's
even sites like i use one called
privacy.com it makes fake debit card
numbers that are attached to your real
account uh james childs is a big fan of
that and that really protects you and
you can set a lot of different limits on
there so if she's really that concerned
there's some great tools out there but a
credit card is not the tool to go with
and two fraudulent transactions two of
anything shouldn't be enough to cause
you to completely change the way you
handle your money no people freak out it
sounds to me like she just wants a
credit card that's what it sounds like
and yeah and so that she can go into
debt and go do a bunch of other crap
with money y'all don't have that's what
it sounds like the credit card is much
more dangerous for your financial future
than any chance of fraud on a debit card
that's the truth
mic drop